alles andere als ein politisches land
jetzt wollen wir einmal direkt zu armin
laschet schauen denn er spricht jetzt
das erste mal als kandidat der union im
kanzlerin setzt cdu-ministerpräsident
armin laschet un-generalsekretär zehn
jahre zuerst spricht herz im irak und
dann verlasse dann wird es fragen die
möglichkeit für fragen geben herr
zielmärkte ja vielen dank meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren auch von
meiner seite herzlich willkommen hier im
konrad adenauer haus
es ist eine entscheidende zeit für
unsere partei für cdu und csu
aber es ist vor allem eine entscheidende
zeit für unser land
und deshalb möchte ich zunächst einmal
darauf hinweisen das wichtigste thema
derzeit ist die bekämpfung der pandemie
das bestimmt unser land und kein anderes
thema ist so wichtig und deswegen bleibt
auch die bekämpfung der pandemie der
gradmesser für uns als union
das heißt verantwortung tragen in diesen
zeiten aber auch in der zukunft und das
leitet uns als union fünf monate bis zur
bundestagswahl einer vertrauens wahl für
die zukunft deutschlands
gestern abend hat armin laschet als
kanzlerkandidat das vertrauen der cdu
deutschlands erhalten und heute das
vertrauen der csu
unser dank als cdu gilt markus söder und
auch markus blume und der gesamten csu
für fairness und für die unterstützung
das ist die stärke der gemeinsamen union
nach einer sehr langen und sehr offenen
sitzung wo alle argumente und positionen
ausgetauscht wurden hat der cdu-vorstand
eindeutig entschieden jedem wurde raum
gegeben über 60 wortmeldungen in dieser
unglaublich langen sitzung armin laschet
hat als bundesvorsitzender der cdu nicht
nur für offenheit und transparenz
gesorgt sondern er hat diese immer
wieder auch während der sitzung
eingefordert wir haben heute mitglieder
des bundesvorstandes nochmal im nachgang
berichtet dass sie sich nicht erinnern
können wann das letzte mal so lange
so intensiv so fair und vor allem so
offen diskutiert wurde
alles ist auf dem tisch gekommen alle
argumente alle erkenntnisse alle
positionen auch und vor allem natürlich
auch das meinungsbild in den
verschiedenen regionen deutschlands an
der basis in den verschiedenen anderen
gremien ist erörtert worden
aber am ende und so ist es in einer
demokratie gibt es eine entscheidung und
armin laschet hat auch nicht nur in der
sitzung gestern sondern auch in seinem
ganzen leben und auch in den jahren in
funktionen in partei und auch in
regierungsämtern bewiesen l stark
insbesondere wenn es drauf ankommt und
das haben wir gestern wieder erlebt wir
sind davon überzeugt dass diese
bundestagswahl nicht nur eine
vertrauens- wahl ist sondern vor allem
auch eine richtungswahl
es geht darum ob wir den kurs der mitte
in deutschland fortsetzen oder ob unser
land von einem linksbündnis regiert wird
das wollen wir verhindern
für diesen kurs der mitte steht armin
laschet und die gesamte union
wir sind der garant als cdu und csu dass
deutschland in der mitte bleibt meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren armin
laschet ist deshalb auch der
kanzlerkandidat einer starken union er
ist der kanzlerkandidat der
gesellschaftlichen mitte in deutschland
armin laschet hat und das wissen wir
alle in der cdu und auch in der csu
er hat die kraft und die ideen um
deutschland zu erneuern damit
deutschland auch in zukunft ein
wirtschaftlich starkes land ist armin
laschet ist ein leidenschaftlicher
europäer
das ist vielen auch gerade vielen
jüngeren besonders wichtig armin laschet
steht für zusammenhalt er kann führen
und er kann zusammenführen
armin laschet ist ein erfahrener
regierungschef das ist auch wichtig für
ein so großes land wie deutschland und
deswegen lassen sie mich ganz persönlich
aber auch im namen der cdu sagen
auch für die union am heutigen tage für
die gesamte union armin laschet ist der
richtige kanzler für deutschland
meine damen und herren wir haben in den
letzten tagen eine sehr intensive eine
sehr transparente eine sehr offene
debatte geführt wir haben es uns nicht
leicht gemacht weil es schließlich um
etwas geht
es geht im september um eine wegweisende
entscheidung für die zukunft unseres
landes
die muss sorgsam abgewogen werden alle
argumente müssen auf den tisch aber es
kommt auch der moment der entscheidung
und der war gestern abend und wir haben
entschieden welches personelle angebot
cdu und csu machen
wir sind in der cdu der csu dankbar für
den guten fairen umgang in einer sehr
weitreichenden entscheidung auch in
einer sehr persönlichen entscheidung und
gut und vertrauensvoll
das gilt und auch das will ich am
heutigen tag betonen für das persönliche
verhältnis von markus söder und mia
die csu hat durch ihre entscheidungen
vom gestrigen tag die entscheidung der
cdu ermöglicht das ist ein großer
vertrauensbeweis und markus söder hat
gesagt der bundesvorstand der cdu muss
entscheiden und in diesem bewusstsein
hat der bundesvorstand gestern ein sehr
deutliches votum getroffen und ich danke
markus söder dafür dass er der cdu und
auch mir persönlich die unterstützung
der csu und auch des parteivorsitzenden
der csu zugesagt hat
sie merkt dass er während viele
langjährige mitglieder haben gesagt so
transparent so offen haben wir in diesem
gremium vielleicht noch nie diskutiert
ich wünsche mir dass diese kultur der
transparenz auch in sachen scheidung in
der zukunft die arbeit der cdu
auszeichnet denn die fragen die vor uns
liegen brauchen genau diese transparenz
brauchen das pro und contra durch
diskussion entsteht lebendigkeit in der
demokratie entsteht moderne demokratie
im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert alle
positionen wurden gehört und
ausgetauscht und der bundesvorstand ist
ja das gremium wo auch alle vertreten
sind alle landesvorsitzenden alle
vereinigungen die für die cdu
traditionell sehr wichtig sind der
sozialflügel und der wirtschaftsflügel
die jungen und die alten
die frauen-union die kommunalpolitiker
alle haben ihre positionen eingebracht
und dieser bundesvorstand vereint auch
die beiden fraktionen das votum der
cdu-fraktion cdu csu fraktion im
deutschen bundestag ist wichtig das
votum unserer kollegin im europäischen
parlament ist wichtig denn die
entscheidung wer bundeskanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland ist ist immer
zugleich auch eine frage auf die viele
menschen in ganz europa blicken und ich
weiß auch dass sich manche eine andere
entscheidung gewünscht hätten so ist das
in einer demokratie
bei der dann am ende unter gewichtung
aller argumente
am ende entschieden wird ich bin markus
söder dankbar dass er gestern noch
einmal die bedeutung der repräsentativen
demokratie unterstrichen hat der konsens
in einer gesellschaft die zunehmend
polarisiert ist kann nur in
gemeinschaftlichen institutionen gelegen
in den parteien und am ende auch im
parlament als dem ort in dem diskutiert
wird und am ende auch entschieden wird
ab jetzt zählt welche partei hat die
besten konzepte für die zukunft unseres
landes wer formiert das beste team um
die herausforderungen zu bewältigen
und deshalb ist es jetzt wichtig dass
die union cdu und csu jetzt als team in
den wahlkampf gehen
die cdu gewinnt diese wahl nicht ohne
die csu und umgekehrt
cdu und csu seien schwester ein in der
deutschen parteiengeschichte
einzigartiges phänomen cdu kandidiert in
15 ländern die csu kandidiert in bayern
und mit diesem modell sind cdu und csu
stabilitätsanker unserer republik
geworden und immer wieder in den
unterschiedlichen phasen auch
modernisierungs motor unseres landes und
gemeinsam werden wir dieses land in die
zukunft führen und markus söder wird
eine zentrale rolle dabei spielen für
die zukunft der bundesrepublik
deutschland ich werde mich weiterhin
täglich zwei täglich wöchentlich wann
immer es nötig ist mit ihm abstimmen und
diese abstimmungen sind trotz eines
wettbewerbs und unterschiedliche akzente
in den letzten tagen immer von dem
willen getragen am ende zu einem
gemeinsamen ergebnis zu kommen und ich
freue mich darauf dass bei den
entscheidungen die anstehen wie auch
dieses gemeinsam schaffen was wir in der
pandemie gelernt haben sind neue formate
diskussionen unmittelbar mit den
kreisverbänden mit unseren mitgliedern
und wir werden dieses stärken ich will
den dialog ich will die innovativen
formaten
denn durch jede dieser diskussionen
erfährt man viel über die vielfalt in
unserem land und die arbeit vor ort
als ich in die cdu in meiner jugend
eingetreten bin habe ich das nie mit der
vorstellung gemacht einmal bundeskanzler
zu werden
meine motivation war damals voller
idealismus einen beitrag zu leisten zu
einer besseren welt und das leben von
menschen konkret zu verbessern was immer
in der kommunalpolitik beginnt für mich
war aber auch wichtig dass politik nie
nur reden ist sondern auch zuhören
menschen zu hören die durch ihre eigene
schilderung ihres eigenen lebens zu
politischen entscheidungen einen beitrag
leisten zu hören entscheiden handeln
das waren für mich drei leitplanken die
mich bis zum heutigen tag prägen und
policy mir hat das erwähnt bei allem was
wir über die zukunft denken kommt es
jetzt darauf an die pandemie zu
bekämpfen das ist das wichtigste leben
zu retten in diesen letzten wochen und
monaten bis wir es geschafft haben dass
ein großteil der menschen in unserem
land geimpft sind
und deshalb steht das auch im
mittelpunkt der beratungen der
bundestagsfraktion und des deutschen
bundestages und des bundesrates in
dieser woche aber von politik erwartet
man auch über den tag hinaus zu denken
wir werden nach der pandemie soziale
wirtschaftliche kulturelle folgen zu
bewältigen haben
wir haben große
haushalterische herausforderungen nach
der pandemie wir lindern derzeit viele
herausforderungen durch die aufnahme von
schulden aber nachhaltigkeit heißt die
nach der krise auch im interesse
künftiger generationen wieder
zurückzuzahlen
und es darf kein weiter so geben wir
müssen als land besser schneller
moderner werden
dieser modernisierungsschub ist jetzt
nötig er war ohnehin nötig aber er ist
nach der pandemie noch nötiger mehr
innovation mehr vertrauen weniger
bürokratie nicht die vorstellung mit
vorschriften und verordnungen kriegt man
bis ins letzte jedes lebens detail
gelöst den menschen etwas zutrauen das
ist der grundgedanke der unionspolitik
auszeichnet wir müssen vielfalt als
chance sehen und nicht als bedrohung und
wir brauchen das neue
aufstiegsversprechen gerade kinder haben
gelitten unter dieser pandemie weil die
sozialen kontakte häufig weggefallen
sind
jedes kind soll aber unabhängig von der
herkunft seiner eltern den aufstieg
schaffen können in unserem land und da
wird die aufgabe nach der pandemie noch
größer sein als sie ohnehin schon ist
und wir wissen wir werden als
deutschland nicht stark wenn europa
nicht stark ist und deshalb auch unsere
nachbarn werden nach der pandemie vor
großen herausforderungen stehen und die
werden wir nur gemeinsam europäisch
beantworten können dass deutschland das
ich mir vorstelle wirkt mit an einem
bündnis von demokratien in der welt
gemeinsam mit unseren transatlantischen
partnern mit dem festen glauben
an multilaterale lösungen und unser
beitrag als europa muss offensiver
werden in einer welt auch autoritärer
gesellschaftsmodelle wir müssen für
unsere werte von freiheit von
solidarität von gerechtigkeit von
menschenwürde kämpfen in dieser welt das
muss europa wieder ausstrahlen dass es
einen die harmonie gesagt hat beitrag
leisten will für eine bessere welt und
unser land führt in der welt nicht durch
größe und einschüchterung sondern durch
exzellenz durch vorbild und durch
menschlichkeit dass deutschland das ich
mir vorstelle ist ein modernes land das
zusammenhält ein land in dem jeder
seinen persönlichen lebensentwurf leben
und danach streben kann seine wünsche zu
erfüllen es ist ein deutschland der
vielfalt der diversität und dieses
zusammenleben wird aber nur gelingen
wenn wir eine gemeinsame basis haben die
werte unseres grundgesetzes gelten
rechthaberei aggression polarisierung
schaden dem zusammenhalt in unserem land
und gerade wenn wir modernisieren wollen
ist vertrauen eine wichtige währung und
das ist mein ziel
so arbeite ich seitdem ich politisch
tätig bin menschen zusammenführen mit
klaren ideen am ende auch entscheiden
und für uns als cdu und csu bedeutet das
dass wir die wir in vielen jahren
unserer republik in kritischen
situationen führungsverantwortung
wahrgenommen haben dass wir auch nach
dieser pandemie
unseren beitrag leisten wollen für eine
gute zukunft und für ein modernes
deutschland